PATRICK WINSTON: It's too bad,
in a way, that we can't paint
everything black, because this
map coloring problem sure
would be a lot easier.
So I don't know what we're
going to do about that.
How long is this
going to take?
Here's what we're going to do.
We're going to wait till either
all the laptops are
closed, or this program
terminates,
whichever comes first.
So how long is this
going to take?
I actually don't know.
I think it'll take more than the
life time of the universe,
but I'm not sure.
So let's take a look at
a slightly easier
map coloring problem.
We'll stop this one and change
the map to something I call
[? simplicia. ?]
There's 26 states, one for each
letter in the alphabet.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to do a depth
first search for a suitable
coloring of this map.
We're going to go in order,
A, B, C, D, E. And as I've
suggested here, at each level
we're going to rotate the
color choices so we don't
over use any one color.
So if we launch this particular
search, this depth
first attempt to
color this map.
There it goes.
And maybe we should wait
until it terminates.
Or maybe we should just let it
run and it'll terminate,
perhaps, sometime within
the lecture.
Or maybe we should just let
it run over the weekend.
Or how long do you think we
would have to wait, if we want
to come back and watch
it terminate?
At roughly 30 frames
a second--
I'm calculating it all in my
head, I don't want to bet my
life on it-- but I think
about 5,000 years.
And if we want to use as many
states as there are in the
United States, in this
demonstration, you get up to
numbers like 10 to
the 17th years--
17th, 18th, 16th, I'm
not exactly sure.
I did a rough calculation.
And, of course, you could do
some parallels into that, and
it's not as bad as chess, where
you need all the atoms
in the universe and you
still can't do it,
and things like that.
Acting as computers.
But still, it's pretty
horrendous.
The problem is, well the problem
is illustrated by this
diagram I put in back of me.
If you do a depth first
search and you have a
problem like Texas.
If you label... if you
assign a color to Arizona,
Oklahoma, Arkansas, and
Louisiana first, and then wait
around to Texas last, then you
get yourself into a bind by
your fourth choice, that you
don't discover until you're
48th choice.
So what happens then, is that
you start developing this tree
like this, you get to those
states surrounding Texas.
Texas is last state assigned
a color and there's
nothing left for it.
And that problem was there on
the fourth choice, and you
don't discover it until
your 50th choice.
So you develop a horrendous,
impossible, impossible search.
So you simply can't
do it that way.
But now, not to worry.
I've come equipped with
the idea of constraint
propagation.
So we could just take
a country with four
states, like this.
Each can be labeled red,
green, blue and yellow.
So just like in a case of line
drawings, we'll pile up all
the possible things that the
value can be-- red, green,
blue and yellow.
Red, green, blue and yellow.
And we start up constraint
propagation.
So we say for the upper left
hand corner state, is there
any reason to believe that
R is impossible?
Well we look at our neighbors
and see what kind of
constraint flows in from them.
And sure, this guy could
be green, and this
guy could be blue.
They don't have to be red,
so there's nothing
that rules out red.
And there's nothing the
rules out blue.
And there's nothing that
rules out yellow.
rules out green.
So constraint propagation just
sits there with its finger up
its nose, doing nothing.
So it doesn't look like we can
use either depth first search,
or constraint propagation.
So we could just give
up and cry.
But maybe there's some other
approach that will help.
So let me actually work
the Texas problem.
So with apologies to
Houston and Tyler,
here's a map of Texas.
There we are.
And here's, roughly
speaking, Arizona
is over here somewhere.
And we've got Oklahoma
in there.
And old Bill Clinton's
state, Arkansas.
And then Louisiana sticks
out there a little bit.
So there's our map of that
particular part of the country.
So we've got Arizona here,
Oklahoma here, Arkansas here,
and Louisiana here,
and Texas here.
And we have elected to assign
colors to these states, in
that order.
So this is one, two,
three, four.
And we're going to do that.
We're going to rotate our color
choices, just so we
don't over use any one color.
But we're going to also have a
look at Texas as we go around.
Because Texas is a state that
borders on the States they
were choosing colors for.
So the only possible colors that
Texas could be are red,
green, blue, and yellow.
So as we make our choices around
here, we'll say that--
we don't have to adhere to any
particular style-- we can say
that Arizona is going to get
the colored red, R. That's
going to rule out R over here
for Texas, because no adjacent
states can have the
same color.
Then we go over to Oklahoma, and
we're rotating our color
choices, so we'll say
that can be green.
And that's fine, because it's
consistent with the red here,
but it rules out the
possibility that
Texas could be green.
And then we go over here to
Arkansas, red, green, blue.
That's fine, that's consistent
with the green on Oklahoma,
but if we look at its neighbors
we know that Texas
is forever forbidden
to be blue, now.
So now we go over to Louisiana,
and remember, we're
rotating our color choices
because we don't want to
overuse them.
So this means that the first
choice we're going to make
here, for Louisiana,
is yellow.
And that's fine because it's
consistent with Arkansas, but
it's not so fine because it's
now ruled out the last
possibility for Texas.
So even though Texas is going
to be the 48th state that we
color, we're going to say,
at this point, there's no
need in going on.
We'd better back up.
Because there's nothing left for
Texas when we get around
to coloring it.
So that means that this yellow
is ruled out here.
This yellow reappears.
We select the next color in my
line for Louisiana, which
happens to be red.
And now that's consistent
with this yellow that's
still left for Texas.
And it's also consistent
with the blue
that's up here for Arkansas.
So that's cool.
I wonder if maybe we could make
an algorithm out of that,
and solve problems like this.
Do you see, sort of, the
intuition of what we're doing?
We're actually using the martial
arts principle, again.
Because the whole problem is
that local constraints,
undiscovered local constraints,
are causing
downstream problems.
So we're going to use the
enemy's powers against him,
and we're going to look at those
local constraints as we
go and make sure they're not
going downstream, not going to
get us later on.
So now I'm going to look like
I'm getting a little formal,
but I'm just getting a little
bit more formal.
Because I want to have some
language that I can use to
describe what's going on, so
that it's clear what the
choices are.
So to start off with, we're
going to have to have some
vocabulary.
So let's start up our
vocabulary here.
We're going to have a notion
of a variable v. And that's
something that can have
an assignment.
There's nothing complicated
about that.
And a value.
A value x is something that
can be in assignment.
It's a little bit circular,
but we're all in computer
science so you know
what I mean.
So the next thing is a little
slightly less obvious, and
that's the notion
of a domain, d.
And that's going to be
a bag of values.
OK.
So one more thing.
A constraint.
That's a constraint
c, is a limit on--
in our examples it's mostly
going to be pairs of
variables, pairs of
variable values.
But in general, it could
be variable values.
So if we go back here to Texas
we could say, OK, how does our
vocabulary drape itself over
that configuration?
And the answer is, the states
have the role of variables,
the colors have the
role of values.
And the domains are the
remaining color possibilities
that we can still use on
a particular state.
And the constraint, in this
case, is the simple map
coloring constraint that no
states that share a boundary
can have the same color.
So states are variables, colors
are values, domains are
bags of colors, and
constraints--
there's only one--
adjacent states can't
have the same color.
So that's how it fits with
this vocabulary.
So now, what did I
actually do here?
Well what I actually did here,
I'm going to now formalize a
little by writing it down
in pseudo code.
So here we are, we're going to
have a look at what we did
here with our intuition,
and we're going to
reduce it to a procedure.
And here's the procedure.
Remember, we're doing depth
first search on this stuff.
I did a depth first search.
We're going to do a depth first
search, and for each
depth first search
assignment--
OK, so here I am, I'm labeling
Arizona, and then Oklahoma,
and then Arkansas, and
then Louisiana.
When I give each one of those a
label, a color, I'm going to
do this procedure.
Every time I make one of
those assignments.
The last one that caused
trouble was
coloring Louisiana yellow.
Each time I put one of those
colors down, each time I make
an assignment, I'm going
to do this procedure.
So for each depth first search
assignment, for each variable
v, considered.
Now you don't know what
I mean by considered.
But when I put a label, when I
put up a value, show something
as a color for Louisiana,
I thought about Texas.
So I was considering the
variable, Texas, when I made
the assignment for Louisiana.
Now I'm going to be a little bit
vague about what I mean by
considered, right now.
Because there are lots of
choices about how much stuff
you actually consider.
So let me just say consider,
and then we'll open that up
and talk about the options in a
moment, so for each variable
v considered for--
let's call that variable
v sub i--
for each x sub i, for each value
in the domain of that
variable, consider each of the
things that still surviving.
For each of those, for each
constraint c, that's between x
sub i, and some x sub j, where
x sub j is an element of the
domain of j.
Now that sounds awfully fancy,
but this just says, in the
case of Texas up there, whenever
I consider one of the
values that's still remaining as
a choice for Texas, I want
to consider all of the
constraints between that
variable and the adjacent
states.
And I want to be sure that
anything I leave in the domain
is OK for some selection in
the other states, some
remaining choices in
the other states.
So that's why we're getting
pretty nested here.
But we're doing depth
first search.
We are considering the variables
in a certain
collection of variables.
For each one of those where
considering all the values
that still remain in the domains
of those variables.
And then for each of those
values, we're checking to see
if it satisfies this some
constraint, satisfies the
constraint that are
placed upon it.
So for each of these constraints
if there does not
exist an x sub j, such that, the
constraint between x sub i
and x sub j is satisfied, well
if in that adjacent place
there's nothing that is
consistent with a value, then
we've got to get rid of it.
If that's true.
If there does not exist some
value in an adjacent variable
such that that constraint is
satisfied, we're hosed.
We've got to get rid
of that value.
So we're going to remove
x sub i from d sub i.
OK.
Now, that's fine.
That's sort of what
I did with Texas.
As soon as I plopped down a
value for Louisiana I said,
well what are the possible
values in Texas?
Red, green, blue and yellow.
Let's consider red.
Let's consider the constraints
between Texas and
all adjacent states.
One of those constraints
says it can't be the
same color as Arizona.
The only color I've got
available for Arizona, since
I've already made the
assignment is red.
Red is not consistent with
red, so I've got
to get rid of it.
So it looks complicated, but
it's just intuition.
So what do we do if we get
to a situation where
the domain is empty?
That means whenever we get
around to making assignment to
it, there won't be
anything left.
So if that ever happens, if the
domain ever becomes empty,
then what do we do?
We've got to back up.
So the intuition is clear.
This is the algorithm.
The algorithm when you work
through it, think about
whether it makes sense
and what not.
How it fits with Texas.
Yeah, it sure does.
All we're doing is we're making
these death first
assignments.
And in the neighborhood of those
depth first assignments
we're looking around to see if
the values that are possible
include something.
And if they don't include
anything, we know we made and
irrevocable blunder, and
we have to back up.
So that's the essence
of the idea.
Now, how well does it work?
Well a little bit depends on
what we choose for considered.
There are lots of choices
for what we consider.
So let me enumerate some of
those choices and then we'll
have a look and see
what they do.
Oh I guess one possibility
is to consider nothing.
Let's try it out.
So our type of search is
going to be no checks.
What do you think is
going to happen?
We're not even checking
the assignment.
That's pretty fast.
Unfortunately, since we haven't
even check the most
recent assignment, we get lots
of places where there are
states that are adjacent
to each other that
have the same color.
That's no good.
So another thing we can do
is consider everything
everything.
That's no good, because that
would say, as soon as we color
our first state, we check to
make sure that all 47 other
states can be colored.
That seems like it over
doing it a little bit.
But in any case, at least we
want to check the assignment.
So if we go back here and check
the assignment, let's
see what happens.
Type assignments, assignments
only.
Boom.
Aw, gees, that's where I
got in trouble before.
This is the thing is going to
run for 17 billion years at
nanosecond or something
like that.
It's only a billion years if
you run it at nanosecond
speed, so I guess maybe
you could do that.
Have a fast computer.
But this isn't going to work
because of our unfortunate
choice of Texas as the last
state to be considered, and
the unfortunate coloring of the
four surrounding states
right up front.
And our unfortunate decision to
rotate the color so as to
avoid overdoing any one color.
So this doesn't work.
We know we went to the trouble
of working out the business
with Texas by hand, using the
domain reduction algorithm.
Better make a note
that this is the
domain reduction algorithm.
And what we're going to do is
we're going to check the
neighbors of the assignments.
Just like we did here.
We checked Texas each time
we made one of those four
choices, because it's a neighbor
of all of the choices
of the states that we made.
So one thing to do is
to check neighbors.
This is one, two, three, now
let's see what happens.
Check neighbors only, go.
Shoot, I don't know.
It's OK with Texas, right?
Because it didn't color the
states around Texas with all
of the four color choices.
But it's still getting into
trouble in other places.
Like the states like Missouri,
Kentucky, Virginia, Tennessee,
states with lots
of boundaries.
So I don't know whether
this is going to--
oh, there it finally worked.
It went through a lot
of effort, though.
For the sake of comparison, we
might make a note that it ran
into 9,139 dead ends.
But it did do some good.
It didn't take a length of time
longer than the remaining
part of the universe.
But if it's a good idea to check
the neighbors, if we
make a change to the neighbors,
what might that
suggests that we
do in addition?
Well it might suggest that
if we make a change to a
neighbor, that we check its
neighbors, too, make sure
they're all right.
So another choice
is to propagate.
So propagate through variables
with reduced domains.
Let's see how that works.
Wait a minute.
I must have made a mistake.
Let's try that again.
Oh, maybe we better
slow it down.
All that grey stuff is showing
the limit of the propagation.
Man it's, let's see at
four second of 40,
that's about 10 seconds.
Boom.
Not bad.
Zero dead ends.
And it was a lot faster.
I didn't happen to notice how
many constraints were checked
on that other thing, I think
it was around 20,000 or so.
This is a lot less.
So this looks like
a good idea.
But why did I label
it number five?
Well because there's something
between this and number three.
So number four is, through v
with d reduced to one value.
So we're not going to propagate
through all of the
variables which have their
domains shrunk a little bit.
We're only going to propagate
through those that have the
greater shrinkage, all the way
down to a single value.
So let's see how that
might work.
Anybody want to place any
bets on this one?
Let's see.
We checked 2,623 constraints
last time.
Let's see what happens
this time.
You can see that the extent of
the gray is less, because it's
not propagating so far.
And as we breathily await the
answer, I'd say we've found
our winner.
As this does a couple of dead
ends, but the number of
constraint checked is
less than 1,000.
So in general, with problems
this, you have all of these
choices for what you consider.
You don't want to consider
nothing, because then you're
not honoring your constraints.
You'll certainly want to
consider the things you just
made assignments for, because
otherwise you'll construct a
solution that violates
a constraint.
You don't want to do everything,
because that's
excessive work.
And so checking the neighbors
is a good idea, but it's
always better in practice.
In practice, inevitably it's the
case that it's better to
do some propagation through the
things that you've changed.
How much propagation?
It doesn't seem to do much
good to propagate through
things are just changed.
But it does seem to do some good
to propagate through the
things that have changed
and been
reduced to a single value.
So as soon as you get a neighbor
of some assignment
you just made that has its
domain reduced to a single
value, then you check
its neighbors, too.
So you check the neighbors,
of the neighbors, of the
neighbors, of the neighbors, on
and on and on, as long as
you've found a domain
being reduced.
And not only being reduced, but
reduced to a signal value.
All right?
So that's the demand reduction
algorithm.
And I guarantee you a
problem like that.
And I know you don't know how
to work those problems yet,
because this is a little
bit abstract.
And to work these problems in
the exam setting you need to
know a little bit about how to
keep track of the variable
values that remain in
the domain, and
that sort of thing.
And you'll learn more about that
in your recitations, and
in this mega recitation,
and in the tutorials.
So we could go home except
that there are few little
flourishes to deal with here.
And those flourishes,
include some dirty,
filthy little secrets.
For example, I've chosen,
as my classroom
example, to pick on Texas.
And arranged for this
situation to
be especially ugly.
So I could arrange the states
in a different way.
We have highly constrained
states, that have a lot of
bordering states around them.
And we have other states, like
Maine, up there, that only
borders on one other state.
So I don't know.
Will, what do you think?
Should we arrange the states for
our death first search in
the order of least constrained
to most constrained, or most
constrained to least
constrained?
In other words, should we
start with Missouri, or
Tennessee, or Kentucky, or
something like that?
Or should we start with Maine?
What do you think?
You have a 50% chance of getting
it right, just by
[? looking ?] at points.
WILL: Start with
the most first.
PROF.
PATRICK WINSTON: He thinks we
should start with the most
constraint first.
Do we have a volunteer who wants
to suggest that we start
with the least constraint
first?
That's the way I always
work on stuff.
I'm working on a book or
something, I have 500 things
to fix, I'll always choose to
work on the easiest stuff
first, so that I feel like I'm
making the list a lot smaller.
Leave the hardest
things to last.
But we don't have any volunteers
who want to bet on
that idea of least
constraint first?
OK.
Jason wants to suggest that
we should work on least
constraint first.
Well we have ground
truth, because we
can just try it out.
I guess we'll stick with
our shrinking to one
value thing, here.
But we will reorder things
so that we have the least
constrained first.
So right away, we got
a color for Maine.
Maybe we ought to speed
this up a little bit.
Well, that's a good idea.
Jason suggested this and we only
1,732 constraints and we
had 59 dead ends.
So let's try the other way
around, and we'll go back to
four frames a second.
So we're working, kind of from
the middle of the country out,
with this one.
We're going to deal with
Maine, I guess, last.
Which is better.
Too bad, I think it looks
like this is better.
In fact, let's not be so
aggressive with the use of
constraint propagation.
Let's just check the
assignments only.
If we go back to an arrangement
where we have
least constrained first, and
we'll crank up the speed.
Well actually, we would have
to crank it up pretty big,
because the states like
Missouri, Tennessee, Kentucky,
they're going to
be like Texas.
And so were kind of back to
the length of the universe
type problem, here.
With the least constraint
first, and no use of
constraints, other than to check
the current assignment.
So let's stop that, though, and
check the most constrained
first, assignments only.
I don't know how long's
this going to take.
That's the dirty
little secret.
If we had arranged our states
from most constrained to least
constrained, ordinary depth
first search with none of this
stuff we talked about today
would work just fine.
All right.
So it's a little
bit like games.
Do you use progressive
deepening, or do
you use alpha beta?
And the answer is both.
You use everything you've got
to deal with the problems.
And depending on the problem,
one or another of the things
you incorporate into your
approach will work just great,
if you're lucky.
So now, I promise that this is
useful not only for people who
want to color maps.
God, who wants to do that?
We know it can be done
with four colors.
But it's also useful for
doing all kinds of
resource planning problems.
So I want to show you a resource
planning problem, and
I want you think about--
while I'm doing it--
think about whether it's
actually analogous to the map
coloring problem.
All right?
So here's the deal.
You have just landed a summer
job with the Jet
Green, a new airline.
And Jet Green is a low cost,
no frills, hardly any
maintenance type of airline.
And they want to fly mostly
between Boston and New York.
Occasionally they want to
fly to Los Angeles.
And they're trying to
get by with the
smallest number of airplanes.
So that's why we have a kind of
resource allocation problem
with Jet Green.
So I'm going to write
down what their
schedule looks like.
They have one flight, F1,
that goes from Boston
to JFK, like so.
It's an early in
the day flight.
Then they want to have
another one, F2, that
flies from JFK to Boston.
And then they want to have
another flight a little later
in the day that flies
from Boston to JFK.
And a little later than that,
they want to have another
flight that goes from
JFK to Boston.
They're going to start off
mostly as a shuttle airline in
the beginning.
So that's F1, F2, F3, and F4.
And they have a fifth flight,
F5, that goes from Boston to
Los Angeles, that takes
a long time.
So it looks like this
on the schedule.
Of course we have time
going that way.
So that's Boston to LAX.
Now your job is to determine if
they can fly this schedule
with four aircraft?
And naturally you don't want to
over use any one aircraft,
because you would like to
have even wear on them.
Right?
So as you make your choices,
you'll rotate the aircraft.
So you'll assign to this one
to A1, aircraft number one.
This one will be A2.
This one will be A3.
And this one will be A4.
And, oops, there's no aircraft
left for the flight to Los
Angeles, because you
only have four.
So, it's obvious, right?
This is 100%, exactly, the map
coloring problem, even down to
the four choices.
Because, you have the
constraint, the no single
physical aircraft can fly two
flights at the same time.
Just like no two adjacent
states can
be colored the same.
So there's a no same time
constraint, like so.
So if you were assigning
aircraft to these flights, you
would get down to F4, the fourth
flight, and you would
say, well, let's see, this
guy down here can be
A1, A2, A3, or A4.
But if I choose A4 for that
fourth flight, then there
would be nothing left
in its domain.
So you've thus set the problem
up to be identical to the map
coloring problem.
And, of course, you can enrich
it with other kinds of
constraints.
So, for example, you
might have--
this is a not same
time constraint--
and these, I mean,
this is at JFK.
And it flies out of JFK, so
maybe you can use the same
aircraft for those.
But not if they're right up
against each other, because
you have a minimum
ground time rule.
So there's a minimum ground
time constraint here.
And there's a minimum ground
There's a minimum ground
time constraint here.
And if these are at the same
city, then you've got to allow
enough time for them to fly
between the two cities that
are involved.
So the constraints can get a
little bit more complicated,
but the idea is the same.
So you say to me, I don't
trust you, show me.
OK.
So let me show you.
Oh, by the way, there's one
more way to make this map
coloring problem
easier, right?
Let's see.
The arrangement is going to be
alphabetical, the type is
going to be assignments only,
and we know that's a loser.
But not if we use a whole
lot of colors.
So it's the use of four colors
that got us into trouble.
Now that's an aside, but
it'll be coming back
in a moment or two.
Scheduling, here's
that problem.
Boom.
You can almost see it working
just like the
map coloring thing.
But that's maybe too easy.
Let's do this one.
See this is just like
[? simplicia. ?]
We've kind of got a goofy
arrangement here that's
guaranteed to lose at the bottom
because of choices made
at the top.
But that's OK.
We can that we can stop this,
and we can change to check
neighbors only.
And boom, there it goes.
Or alternatively, let me see
if I can do it this way.
Most constrained first, type
will be assignments only.
Boom.
That worked fine, too.
So you might choose to have
a slightly harder
problem, like this.
And we can search away.
Actually I don't know if this
will complete or not.
This is a randomly generated
example.
But you're going to lose your
summer job if you can't figure
out whether you can
do this, or not.
So what are you going to do?
[? Elliott, ?] you got any
thoughts about how you're
going to save your job?
So here's the question
you've been asked.
How many airplanes does
Jet Green need?
And you decide, well, four
seemed to work before, so
we'll try four here.
You're not sure if it's going
to terminate or not, I mean,
in your lifetime, let alone
in your summer job.
[? Elliott, ?] let me
give you a hint.
Look at the outline.
The outline up here, on the
board, the last item.
[? ELLIOTT: [INAUDIBLE] ?]
PROF.
PATRICK WINSTON: Yeah,
what's that mean?
What's the maximum number of
airplanes we're going to need?
Suppose we've got five flights,
what's the maximum
number of airplanes we
would ever need?
Five.
What's the minimum number
of airplanes we'll need?
One.
So let's try it with a small
number of airplanes and a
large number of airplanes.
So that showed us very
fast that we can't
do it with one airplane.
That showed us very fast we can
do it with ten airplanes.
SPEAKER 1: [INAUDIBLE]
amount of overlappage
from up [INAUDIBLE].
PROF.
PATRICK WINSTON: Volunteer?
What are we going to do to find
the actual number, as
fast as possible.
And at least give our boss a
reasonable answer, even if not
necessarily the exact
number very fast?
It's easy, right?
We're going to start up here
with one computer, and we're
going to start down here
with another computer,
and see what happens.
So let's see if we can
do it with nine.
Let's see if we can
do it with eight.
do it with seven.
These take almost zero
time, right?
Because they're under
constraint.
Wow, that's good, seven.
Let's try six.
Actually let's try two.
It loses fast.
Let's try three.
I don't know.
Maybe if you let it run one long
enough three will work.
I doubt it.
While we're at it though, we
might as well go back here and
try it with six.
Remember seven worked
real fast.
Gees, six, that was
six, right?
Yeah.
So let's try it with five.
OK.
So it runs real fast
with five.
It terminates real quick
with two, so we got
three and four left.
So we could tell our boss, a
la any time algorithm, that
you're not real sure, but you
know it's going to be either
three or four.
And then, you got
two computers.
You can let both run and see
if either one terminate.
So you have three and four.
My guess is that three will
eventually give up.
But of course, there's another
little problem here.
We haven't used the most
constraint first.
If we did that, we might be
able to do it even faster.
Actually, I don't think I can
make that switch without
getting another random
assignment, but
let's see what happens.
Maybe so.
SPEAKER 2: [INAUDIBLE]
PROF.
PATRICK WINSTON: Oh, I already
had most constraint first?
OK.
So it didn't help to
actually switch.
And I think I've got a new
schedule to work here.
So that's the end
of the story.
You can do good resource
allocation if you do several
things are once.
Number one, you always want to
use most constraint first.
Number two you want to propagate
through domains
produced to a single
algorithm.
And number three, if you really
try to figure out what
the minimum number of resources
needed is, you do
this under over business and you
can quickly converge on a
narrow range where the search is
taking a long time, and be
sure that it lies within
that narrow range.
Because when you over resource,
it's fast to
complete, and when you
under resource,
it's fast to terminate.
So you can just squeeze
it right down into
a very small range.
And that is the end
of the story.
Enjoy your holiday on Monday.
We'll have two classes next week
on Wednesday and Friday,
as advertised.